und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka gegen
abend der völkerrechtliche begriff der
inneren angelegenheiten eines staates in
denen sich andere nicht einzumischen
haben wird ja seit jeher vor allem von
diktatorischen staat gern bemüht sobald
es von außen kritik an
menschenrechtsverletzungen oder
ähnlichen gibt insbesondere in den
zeiten des kalten krieges war der
vorwurf der einmischung in innere
angelegenheiten aus moskau regelmäßig zu
hören was die sowjetunion aber nicht
davon abhielt sich ihrerseits in die
angelegenheiten anderer länder
einzumischen
heute ist es wieder einmal china das
gegen einmischung protestiert und sogar
mit gegenmaßnahmen droht auslöser sind
zwei gesetzte des amerikanischen
kongresses mit denen die usa sich hinter
die demokratiebewegung in hongkong
stellen dritter jäger berichtet die
große fans giving parade in new york ist
das worauf amerika heute schaut kitschig
bunt soll sie an diesem feiertag all die
innen- und außenpolitischen ärgernisse
ausblenden mit denen washington
tagtäglich die nachrichten füllt ruhe
für die amerikaner
wenigstens zum erntedankfest doch die
spitze die ihr mann in weißem haus am
abend zuvor gegen china losgelassen hat
lässt den gegner auf der anderen seite
des globus kochen zwei gesetzte des
us-kongresses unterzeichnete trump mit
denen die usa die demokratiebewegung in
hongkong unterstützt heute habe ich das
gesetz 18 38 das hong kong
menschenrechts und demokratie gesetzt
von 2009/10 unterzeichnet die reaktion
aus china kommt postwendend das
staatsfernsehen verkündet die
einbestellung des us-botschafters in
peking eine einmischung in innere
angelegenheiten sei das empört sich der
sprecher des chinesischen
außenministeriums spricht von einem
komplott und hat drohungen im gepäck die
usa ignorieren die tatsachen vertauschen
schwarz und weiß unterstützen
unverhohlen gewalttätige kriminelle die
unschuldige menschen geschlagen und in
brand gesetzt haben die
rechtsstaatlichkeit mit füßen getreten
und die soziale ordnung gefährdet haben
wir raten den usa nicht stur zu bleiben
andernfalls wird china gegenmaßnahmen
ergreifen und alle sich daraus
ergebenden konsequenzen müssen von den
usa getragen werden
bisher war die chinesische
sonderverwaltungsregion hongkong von
trans strafzöllen im handelskrieg mit
china verschont geblieben
mit dem neuen gesetzen drohen nun auch
hier wirtschafts aktionen
außerdem ist ab sofort die lieferung von
ausrüstung untersagt die die polizei
gegen demonstranten einsetzten kann
kritik an chinas kampf gegen die
demokratiebewegung damit hielt sich
trump immer zurück wohl auch um eine
einigung im handelsstreit nicht zu
gefährden er unterschrieb trotzdem nicht
ganz freiwillig es gab in beiden
kongresskammern eine so überwältigende
überparteiliche mehrheit für die gesetze
dass er keine wahl hatte ein veto von
ihm wäre wieder kassiert worden
der us kongress spricht sich fast
einstimmig für menschenrechte aus und
die protestler fühlen sich bestärkt in
hongkong heute feierei stadt
straßenschlachten
jetzt wo amerika vorgelegt hat hoffen
wir dass die anderen g8 staaten folgen
werden und dann die ganze welt das ist
eine warnung für die regierung wenn sie
die menschen hier nicht respektiert
demokratie und frieden nicht respektiert
dann gibt es eine strafe kam flog heute
nach afghanistan überraschungsbesuch bei
der truppe hier kein wort zu hongkong
oder china heute soll mal ruhe sein es
ist schließlich thanksgiving
tja der seit mehr als einem jahr
anhaltende handelskrieg zwischen china
und den usa
und jetzt noch die androhung von
wirtschaftssanktionen gegen den
finanzplatz hongkong valerie haller in
frankfurt wie reagieren die finanzmärkte
auf diese neue entwicklung noch recht
gelassen das hat übrigens auch damit zu
tun dass us-präsident trump den
zeitpunkt seiner unterschrift ziemlich
geschickt gewählt hat nämlich nach
börsenschluss und vor dem thanksgiving
feiertag an dem nicht gehandelt wird
genug zeit also für die märkte
die nachricht erst einmal zu verdauen
trump kennt natürlich die sorge der
anleger
der handelsstreit es schließlich einer
der belastungsfaktoren für die märkte
und sollten die gespräche zu einem
handelsabkommen scheitern würde das
schon ein beben an den börsen auslösen
china hat den deal aber noch nicht
infrage gestellt das erklärt warum der
dax heute nur mäßig verschnupft reagiert
hat auch ist noch völlig unklar ob und
wie die gesetze in hongkong überhaupt
angewandt werden hongkong wird ihr erst
mal einer jährlichen prüfung unterzogen
und ob die stadt noch autonom genug ist
aber dass der ausgang ja noch ziemlich
ungewiss
neben und wenn die usa tatsächlich ernst
machen würden und hongkong seinen
sonderstatus in den
wirtschaftsbeziehungen nach amerika ab
zu aberkennen was wären denn da die
folgen
also das wäre schon ein herber schlag
für die ohnehin schon schwächelnde
wirtschaft chinas der handel zwischen
den usa und hongkong der ist nämlich
immens 38 milliarden dollar schwer
verliert die stadt ihren sonderstatus
dann werden firmen ihr engagement in
hongkong und auch ihre investitionen
schon in frage stellen und nicht nur die
amerikanischen internationale
unternehmen haben dort ja ihren sitz
eben weil sie die relative
unabhängigkeit vom chinesischen festland
und die damit verbundene
rechtssicherheit schätzen und wenn das
gefährdet wäre könnten sie ihre
geschäftsstellen dort abziehen auch viel
hängt davon für die usa ab hongkong ist
für amerikanische firmen zentraler
zugang zum chinesischen markt und das
wird die us-regierung nicht einfach aufs
spiel setzen wollen was also den
handelsstreit betrifft ist eine einigung
durch das us-gesetz sicher nicht
einfacher geworden aber immer noch
möglich beide seiten haben ein interesse
daran den
streit beizulegen beide suchen beide
brauchen eine lösung dankeschön galerie
für die einschätzung
donald trump hat sich nicht nur in einem
mühsamen handelskonflikt mit china
begeben unter dem selbstverständlich
nicht nur die chinesische wirtschaft
leidet darüber hinaus ist ein
wiederkehrendes wahlkampfthema america
first arbeitsplätze sollen zurück in die
usa
andere länder dürften den amerikaner
nicht länger etwas wegnehmen
auch damit begründet er ja neue
importzölle auf ausländische
insbesondere chinesische produkte
dazu passt allerdings nicht so richtig
gut dass ausgerechnet wahlkampf artikel
für donald trump preiswert in china
produziert werden
im südosten der volksrepublik in der
provinzstadt ching arbeiten viele
fleißige hände für trams neues
wahlversprechen keep america great und
voller berichtet ein hauch von
disneyland begrüßt den besucher der
stadt töging hier haben sie keine
probleme kulturen zu mischen
auf dem dach der heimischen textilfabrik
weht stolz die chinesische fahne
aber seit sie in kambodscha noch
billiger produzieren können haben die
chinesen ihre produktpalette erweitert
sie versorgen den tramp wahlkampf mit
wink elementen keep america great diese
fahne ist der große verkaufsschlager
natürlich in den usa seit anfang des
jahres ist die nachfrage nach tram
fahren enorm gestiegen
wir kommen jetzt hole in die heiße phase
des wahlkampfes wir haben vor
bestellungen bis ins nächste jahr
amerikas patriotismus lässt chinas
fahnen industrie reich werden herr jean
ist natürlich kommunist aber eben auch
ein guter geschäftsmann keep america
great made in china ein widerspruch das
ist eine peinliche frage aus
patriotischer sicht mag ich kommt nicht
er hat den handelskrieg angefangen aber
er ist gut für das geschäft meine
privatmeinung spielt da keine rolle
in acht stunden schichten produzieren
sie und verdienen gut dabei rund 600
euro im
chinas arbeiter leben deshalb trump er
und sein wahlkampf machen sie great
again in unserem herzen ist er ein
großartiger mensch einfach super die
kleine fabrik mit 200 arbeiter ist in
die fänge der großen politik geraten der
handelskrieg trifft auch sie weil die
zölle auf textilien und fahnen gestiegen
sind
aber die chinesen sind clever cleverer
als trans schutzzölle wenn wir unsere
fahnen mit einem container in großer
stückzahl verschicken müssen die kunden
den erhöhten strafzoll bezahlen deshalb
verschicken wir kleinere einheiten
pakete die pakete per post sind vom zoll
befreit
für weniger als einen dollar produzieren
sie die tram fahne hier in texas
verlangen händler wie der amerikaner
blake 20 dollar pro flagge er macht gute
geschäfte mit der wut dass die chinesen
dabei helfen stört ihn nicht
es ist doch witzig china produziert die
ganzen tag fahren obwohl sie mit uns in
einem handelskrieg sind am ende glauben
sie wohl an unsere bewegung genau wie
wir nur bullshit kein schwarzen meer
steht auf einer es klingt wie ein
kommentar
20.000 tram fahren produzieren sie im
monat wissen sie was da auf der fahne
steht
nein es gibt doch so viele fahren da
kann ich mir das nicht merken
trumps wut bewegung macht ihre jobs
sicher dass freud sie nur bullshit kein
schwachsinn mehr
mit freundlichen grüßen aus schalding
kommen wir zu einem thema made in
germany die pkw maut sollte bekanntlich
auch ein ganz großer deal werden und
endete in einem debakel
bundesverkehrsminister steht unter druck
und seit heute noch ein bisschen mehr
denn die oppositionsparteien im
bundestag haben sich geschlossen für
einen untersuchungsausschuss
ausgesprochen und zwölfter dezember soll
er seine arbeit aufnehmen mit
zahlreichen vorladungen von zeugen etc
das wird vor allem dafür sorgen dass
dieses für die regierung aber vor allem
für die federführende csu
hochnotpeinliche thema nicht in
vergessenheit gerät
kristin hübsch awp berichtet andreas
scheuer weiß dass es ab jetzt richtig
eng werden könnte
dass er nun akten herausgeben muss die
bisher noch unter verschluss sind das
vielleicht gesprächsprotokolle
auftauchen die es angeblich gar nicht
gibt dass er persönlich vor den
ausschuss geladen wird
er hat dieses szenario bisher immer mit
großer lässigkeit zu überspielen
versucht horst seehofer hat diese woche
zu mir gesagt er hat sechs
untersuchungsausschuss in seinem leben
gehabt bleibt konzentriert aber
untersuchungsausschuss gehört zum
parlament nicht mehr nicht weniger
heute aber ist der minister demonstrativ
nicht da als der bundestag mit den
stimmen von fdp linken grünen und afd
den untersuchungsausschuss zur pkw-maut
offiziell einsetzt die koalitionspartner
enthalten sich handelt ist er aus der u
ausschuss soll nun nachweisen was der
bundesrechnungshof dem minister bereits
zweimal schriftlich gab er habe mit der
maut das vergaberecht verletzt gegen
haushaltsrecht verstoßen und die
großzügige schadensersatz regelungen die
scheuer vorab mit den maut betreibern
schloss sie war nicht angemessen
erscheine wollte die maut durchsetzen
koste es was es wolle gegen den
widerstand seiner beamten hat er vor der
verkündung des urteils des europäischen
gerichtshofs akten geschaffen und
dadurch einen riesigen schaden für den
deutschen steuerzahler von bis zu 500
millionen euro
wir waren konkret wissen was es in den
geheimgesprächen andreas scheuer mit den
konzernchefs von kapsch eventim wirklich
gelaufen das gibt es keine akten
doch wie gefährlich kann das was jetzt
kommt für scheuer wirklich werden ein
blick ins archiv ernüchtert er spricht
noch vom u-ausschuss zur berater affäre
von der leyen
die beschuldigte ministerin längst weg
befördert der ausschuss arbeitet weiter
aber gerät zur farce und für rücktritte
muss man tatsächlich lange zurückschauen
1984 tritt rainer barzel in der flick
affäre zurück burning 1993 nach
falschaussage in der barschel-affäre
tatsächlich ist es so dass wenn man die
geschichte der untersuchungsausschüsse
anschaut selten die
untersuchungsausschüsse die instrumente
waren die wirklich zu großen
knalleffekten zu großen politischen
skandalen oder rücktritten geführt
hätten am ende der legislatur noch im
amt ist hängt meiner einschätzung nach
fast alleine von der csu ab denn solange
csu chef markus söder die hand über
andreas scheuer hält kann ihm fast
nichts passieren
die kanzlerin wird keinen minister
entlassen der nicht ihrer partei
angehört mit diesem wissen geht der
u-ausschuss in zwei wochen an die arbeit
den vorsitz bekommt ein spd-abgeordneter
werde auch darauf achten dass hier mit
fairen mitteln anständigen mitteln in
diesem ausschuss gearbeitet wird wir
sind weder ankläger noch sind wir
verteidiger sondern wir sind in diesem
ausschuss auf wäre doch die aufklärung
wird dauern mit einem ergebnis ist nicht
vor anfang 2021 zu rechnen
mehr hintergründe zur maut debakel
finden sie auf heute.de unter anderem
erklärt die politologin schönberger dort
noch ausführlicher was man dem
untersuchungsausschuss zu erwarten ist
ist jetzt macht erst nach heinz wolf
weiter mit anderen nachrichten teil des
tages zunächst aus straßburg dort hat
das europaparlament gefordert mehr für
den klimaschutz zu tun und es hat in
einer resolution den klima notstand
ausgerufen
das hat zunächst keine unmittelbaren
folgen soll aber ein zeichen setzen auch
mit blick auf die weltklimakonferenz
nächste woche in madrid dass zwei
drittel der abgeordneten stimmten bei
der sitzung in straßburg für die
resolution
darin werden die eu kommission und die
mitgliedstaaten unter anderem
aufgefordert den co2 ausstoß deutlich zu
senken und auf das ziel hinzuarbeiten
die erderwärmung auf unter 1,5 grad zu
begrenzen
im bundestag ging es heute weiter mit
den haushaltsberatungen unter anderem
zum etat von
bundesgesundheitsministeriums sparen
der ging in seiner rede auf die
situation in der pflege einsparen
bezifferte die zahl der offenen stellen
mit bis zu 80.000 und verteidigte die
bemühungen um ausländische fachkräfte
der bedarf könne nicht allein mit
arbeitskräften aus deutschland gedeckt
werden
ebenfalls in der haushaltsdebatte
kündigte bundesjustizministerin
lamprecht eine änderung im strafrecht an
die ein deutliches signal gegen
antisemitismus setzen soll
sie werde vorschlagen dass
antisemitische motive ausdrücklich als
strafverschärfend benannt werden sagte
die ministerin
auch bislang schon kann antisemitismus
strafverschärfend berücksichtigt werden
ist aber im gesetz noch nicht
ausdrücklich genannt
frankreichs präsident hat seine aussage
die nato sei hirntot verteidigt und
seine kritik an dem militärbündnis
erneuert bei einem treffen mit
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg in
paris sagte makro die sicherheitspolitik
der nato müsse neu ausgerichtet werden
oder mit der kampf gegen terrorismus
müsse mehr in den mittelpunkt gestellt
und der dialog mit russland verstärkt
werden
außerdem forderte er eine bessere
koordinierung und nannte als
negativbeispiel syrien offensive des
nato partners türkei im irak sind bei
protesten gegen die regierung weitere
mindestens 25 menschen ums leben
gekommen hunderte wurden verletzt viele
von ihnen schwer
sicherheitskräfte setzten tränengas und
schusswaffen ein und die demonstranten
auseinanderzutreiben
zuvor hatten in der südirakischen stadt
nadschaf demonstranten das iranische
konsulat in brand gesetzt
sie werfen iran vor die regierung in
bagdad zu stützen die sie für korruption
und misswirtschaft verantwortlich machen
es etwas zwei monaten halten die
proteste an und mehr als 300 menschen
sind getötet haben es lässt sich
trefflich darüber streiten ob es klug
war die wehrpflicht abzuschaffen
beziehungsweise auszusetzen
es gab gute argumente dafür und dagegen
allerdings ist das jetzt auch vergossene
milch die wehrpflicht ist weg und damit
auch der zivildienst
letzteres macht sich schmerzlich
bemerkbar die zivis fehlen an allen
ecken und enden zu machen auch heute
viele junge leute nach der schule ja
erstmal ja ein jahr pause bevor sie sich
dem arbeitsmarkt zur verfügung stellen
oder mit dem studium beginnen
work and travel ist beliebt und auch für
ein freiwilliges soziales jahr einlegt
verbringt das vielfach lieber in fernen
ländern und nicht in deutschen
altenheimen die cdu vor allem chefin
kramp karrenbauer denkt über eine neue
dienstpflicht nach ein pflichtjahr für
junge männer und frauen dagegen gibt es
allerdings erhebliche bedenken selbst
der sozialverbänden florian berichtet
sie macht das hier freiwillig in einem
pflegeheim in schwerin gegen ein eher
kleines taschengeld ein ganzes jahr lang
bis ihre ausbildung beginnt und jenny
schiller 16 jahre alt ist das kann man
sagen begeistert alle bewohner sind
dankbar das team hier ist auch klasse
also ich kann mir nichts besseres
vorstellen
sie hat sich dieses thema auch
freiwillig ausgesucht und will einen
solchen dienst ob in der pflege beim
bund oder bei der feuerwehr zur pflicht
machen
eine dienstpflicht das war einer der
ersten akzente von annegret
kramp-karrenbauer als
cdu-generalsekretärin 2018 als
parteivorsitzende greift sie die
forderung heute wieder auf
werkstattgesprächen der parteizentrale
es geht darum mal wieder ein thema zu
setzen und tatsächlich um eine ganz
große frage
gibt es überhaupt noch einen kitt der
uns in unserer gesellschaft gemeinsam
zusammen hielt ein dienstjahr als kit
auch um menschen aller schichten
zusammen zu bringen
nur müsste man dafür gar ans grundgesetz
niemand darf zu einer bestimmten arbeit
gezwungen werden heißt es dort bisher
doch weder koalitionspartner noch
opposition würden aktuell bei einer
grundgesetzänderung mitmachen
exemplarisch die haltung des fdp chefs
man kann nicht einfach ein lebensjahr
enteignen für erzieherische zwecke oder
für hilfstätigkeiten wir brauchen in der
pflegefachkräfte das muss angemessen
finanziert werden und an allen ecken und
enden fehlen uns auch sonst fachkräfte
tatsächlich hat kramp karrenbauer ist
mit der idee schon in den eigenen reihen
schwer wie groß die vorbehalte auch in
der cdu sind wird im laufe des gesprächs
heute spürbar
eine stimme von vielen ich halte es für
richtig dass wir an die eine
gemeinschaft sind der menschen gerade
auch die jungen menschen appellieren und
diesen auch fördern wollen ich habe nur
ein problem damit dass wir die jungen
menschen dazu verpflichten wollen aber
würden sich nicht wenigstens die
sozialverbände freuen die bei einer
pflicht plötzlich zig tausende junger
menschen beschäftigen könnten nein sagt
einer der es wissen muss
frank jürgen weise ex chef der
arbeitsagentur 2010 vorsitzender einer
kommission die damals die aussetzung der
wehrpflicht empfahl heute ist weise
präsident der johanniter unfallhilfe und
sagt man sollte lieber auf die setzen
die sich freiwillig melden unsere
gesellschaft sollte ringen um die gute
haltung und einstellung der menschen und
pflicht es sozusagen die letzte option
widerstand gegen ihre dienstpflicht also
quer durch die lager annegret kramp
karrenbauer aber will die idee nicht
aufgeben
es ist klar das ist ein langer weg und
auf diesem weg kann man auch als
zwischenschritte viele verbesserungen im
freiwilligen angebot machen ein langer
weg das war es auch in frankreich noch
im wahlkampf hatte emanuel makro ein
dienst pflichtjahr für alle jungen
franzosen angekündigt im amt und
angesichts der realen möglichkeiten
schrumpften die pläne immer weiter nun
hat die testphase immerhin begonnen
der neue dienst an der französischen
nation dauert gerade mal vier wochen für
eines eignen sich wehrpflicht und
zivildienst oder soziales jahr
aber in der tat gut das leben der
anderen kennen zu lernen mit menschen
orten und lebenswirklichkeiten in
intensiven kontakt zu kommen mit denen
man sonst vielleicht wenig zu tun gehabt
hätte
dieser gedanke steht auch hinter dem zdf
bürgerprojekt zdf in mehrere wochen am
stück leben redakteure und kamerateams
in einer stadt berichten quer durch alle
zdf sendungen und setzen auf
themenvorschläge von den bürgern
ausgewählt wurden orte die in unserer
berichterstattung nicht ständig schon
großen raum einnehmen wie etwa die
hauptstadt berlin oder das finanzzentrum
frankfurt und es wurden städte gewählt
die im wandel sind zum beispiel
altenburg thüringen heißwasser in der
lausitz bottrop im ruhrpott oder aktuell
kaiserslautern in der pfalz model serien
ist fürs zdf in kaiserslautern ein blick
auf 100 jahre industriegeschichte
früher wurden auf dem festgelände in
kaiserslautern nähmaschinen hergestellt
heute wird in asien produziert
zurückgeblieben sind 20 hektar fläche
gifte im boden asbest in den wänden
wir müssen also hier erhebliche mengen
altlasten im boden und im grundwasser
beseitigen wir müssen 80 gebäude
zurückbauen
die über 100 jahre ganz andere
baumaterialien haben als wir sie heute
noch zulässig verbauen dürfen die stadt
kaufte das gelände 2014 für einen euro
wohnungen ein forschungs und
technologiezentrum
all das soll hier entstehen ohne geld
vom land rheinland pfalz undenkbar
sie wiegt schwer die industrielle
vergangenheit
daneben wird bereits an der zukunft
gearbeitet
die technische universität hat in den
vergangenen jahren grundlagenarbeit für
den neuen mobilfunkstandard 5g geleistet
autonomes fahren anwendungen in der
industrie der bund fördert die forschung
mit 12 millionen euro in sachen 5g habe
die stadt schon heute eine
vorreiterrolle
wir merken schon dass es interesse gibt
von der industrie zu sagen na ja gut
also bei der kompetenz häufung die es
inzwischen zeit um die tu kaiserslautern
um die forschungsinstitute rom gibt dann
ist das offensichtlichen standort wo man
vielleicht auch sein sollte von der
industriestadt hin zum standort ein
transformationsprozess der bereits in
weiten teilen vollzogen sei erzählt man
uns doch nicht alle menschen in der
stadt profitieren bisher davon der
asternweg und geranien weg ein sozialer
brennpunkt 168 schlicht unterkünfte im
besitz der stadt
wer hier lebt musste sein zuhause wegen
zwangsräumung verlassen häuser aus den
fünfzigern toiletten und duschen gibt es
in einigen blogs bis heute nur
etagenweise nach und nach wird saniert
zu langsam kritisieren bewohner und
helfer man muss ein minimum in einer
stadt die so weit nach vorne will ein
minimum für die armen leute lassen und
das ist unserer meinung nach busche
warmwasser und heizung altlasten gebe es
in kaiserslautern reichlich erzählt uns
der oberbürgermeister
seit den 90er jahren habe die stadt 800
millionen euro an schulden angehäuft
sie gehört zu den am höchsten
verschuldeten kommunen deutschlands
dennoch schuldenabbau allein helfe
kaiserslautern nicht
dann würden wir die entwicklung in die
zukunft verpassen sondern wir müssen
beides tun
wir müssen die ressourcen die da sind
und die fördermittel die wir akquirieren
einsetzen und die stadt weiter zu
entwickeln und gleichzeitig auch sehen
dass wir von den altschulden wegkommen
die stadt würde es begrüßen wenn der
bund teile der altschulden übernehmen
würde
strukturwandel und schuldenabbau
gleichzeitig aus eigener kraft sei das
nicht zu schaffen
das gelte für viele städte in
deutschland nicht nur für kaiserslautern
und jetzt nochmal meldungen von heinz
wolf die inflation in deutschland liegt
auch im november bei 1,1 prozent im
jahresvergleich dem niedrigsten stand
seit anfang 2008 zehnter das gab das
statistische bundesamt anhand
vorläufiger daten bekannt demnach sind
in diesem november haushaltsenergie und
kraftstoffe günstiger als vor einem jahr
nahrungsmittel dagegen im durchschnitt
etwas teurer
in der fußball europa league hat der vfl
wolfsburg heute abend in der ukraine
gegen alexandria eins zu null gewonnen
wolfsburg steht jetzt bereits sicher in
der ko runde
da auch borussia mönchengladbach hat
eins zu null gewonnen beim
österreichischen verein wolfsberger ac
zehn grad leichter regen wind heute
abend in berlin richtig weihnachtlich
war es noch nicht als bundeskanzlerin
merkel die weihnachtsbäume für ihren
regierungssitz in empfang nahmen den
ehrenhof schmückt jetzt eine
nordmanntanne 14 meter hoch und 20 jahre
alt aus schmalfeld in schleswig holstein
und für das erdgeschoss innen hat die
stadt rottenburg in baden württemberg
eine weißtanne aus ihrem stadtwald
gespendet so und ums liebe geld geht es
heute bei maybrit illner und ihren
gästen was bedeuten die andauernden
nullzinsen für altersvorsorge und sparer
die sollen sich stark und bürger dazu
verhalten und um 0.30 gibt es dann heute
plus mit rainer zimmermann und uns
morgen wieder dann lieber freitags erst
um 22 uhr wieder sehen
[Musik]
mit einem liebe zuschauer im norden wird
es morgen wechselhaft aber wir haben
doch immer mehr sonnenschein dort zu
erwarten das war ja heute ganz anders
regen wird er in deutschland mit einem
tief dass jetzt aber abschied nach
nordosten zieht und dann wird der weg
frei für kühle luft von der nordsee und
dies auch noch ein bisschen trockener
das heißt es lockert eben immer mehr
offene norddeutschland während südlich
des mains teilweise dauerregen gibt
denen es ja auch jetzt in den nächsten
stunden noch geben wird also im
nordwesten lockert es dann aber später
auf einer zweiten nachthälfte haben wir
dann allerdings einen starken wind
sturmböen aus südwesten an der nordsee
auch sonst ist es sehr windig und die
temperaturen erreichen 4 bis 8 grad mit
leichtem bodenfrost vielleicht morgen
früh in schleswig-holstein tagsüber
wechseln sonne und wolken im norden es
gibt aber auch regenschauer die ziehen
so von der nordsee richtung harz aber
auch hier im osten von der ostsee bis
nach brandenburg und abends könnte es
vielleicht an der ostsee auch mal schnee
regen schon geben es bleibt sehr windig
an der ostsee vor allen dingen starker
stürmischer nordostwind und auch in der
mitte freundliches wetter bis zum main
etwa dann haben wir die starke bewölkung
langsam zieht das regengebiet nach süden
und an den alpen sinkt die
schneefallgrenze am abend auf 1000 meter
und zwischen main und donau lockert auch
schon wieder auf die temperaturen sind
nicht mehr ganz so hoch es sind noch
fünf bis zehn grad und in den nächsten
tagen wird es deutlich kühler werden
teilweise haben wir dauerfrost minus ein
grad in den mittelgebirgen am sonntag
mit schnee oder schneeregen im südwesten
und auch am motor ist es noch ziemlich
kalt
ich wünschen einen schönen abend und
machen sie's gut